et même parfois très tendu il vous a dit
par exemple vous êtes des élus et vous
connaissez le cynisme politique mieux
que moi une phrase voilà qui vous a fait
tout de suite réagir vous avez vous
reconnaissez que c'est une audition très
tendue bah il y a tous ceux qui l'ont
écouté vont se rendre compte
qu'effectivement cet étendue oui c'était
tendu parce que je crois d'abord que
Mohamed chifaoui voulait profiter si je
puis dire de cette présence en
commission pour faire passer tout un
ensemble de messages tribunes donc une
sorte de tribune et pendant les quelques
minutes au départ on a bien voulu dès
l'instant où il s'était jamais exprimé
publiquement lui laisser quelques
quelques minutes
d'explications mais ensuite
je crois pas dire une dizaine de minutes
mais je crois c'est que à un moment
donné
il aurait souhaité presque inverser le
système c'est-à-dire faire que soit lui
qui finalement pose les questions d'une
certaine et qu'on se place par rapport à
sa position donc il a fallu très
rapidement mettre les choses au clair il
a dit on s'attaque à mon honneur à ma
réputation qu'est-ce que vous vous
retenez de de son propos voilà on ira
sur des questions plus précises ensuite
mais qu'est-ce que vous retenez vous de
cette de cette audition vous avez appris
des choses que vous ne saviez pas avant
ah oui et on l'a dit par exemple qu'à un
moment donné il y avait une double
rémunération du cipdr c'est quand même
pas tout à fait rien c'est-à-dire un
emploi temps plein dans le cadre du fond
Marianne et également une mission de
consultant contrat de consultant
du cipdr en même temps c'est quand même
si vous voulez qu'il y ait plusieurs
contrats de travail pourquoi pas mais
que le même organisme public donne à la
fois de deux montants dont l'un est
prévu pour un emploi temps plein et que
tout ça soit validé c'est quand même
extraordinaire et alors ce que du coup
c'est pas aussi problématique parce que
vous le découvrez assez tard dans les
auditions quand on explique que lors la
dernière audition vous sachiez ce
contrat de consultant alors que vous
avez auditionné tous les autres
interlocuteurs auparavant qui vous en
ont pas parlé d'abord peut-être parce
que la question ne leur avait été pas
posée de manière aussi précise on n'a
jamais imaginé qu'il y avait un contrat
de cette nature vous pouvez imaginer des
relations étroites on a posé des
questions là-dessus mais on n'a pas
pointé ce point et donc par omission on
va dire le sujet n'est pas venu dans le
débat et d'autre part monsieur Sifaoui
arrive en dernier mais c'est dû à un
certain nombre d'événements qui ont
précédé y compris le fait qu'il était
malade il y a une semaine donc si vous
voulez s'il avait été dans le bon ordre
peut-être les choses auraient été plus
facile à propos du fond de ce que le
fond Marianne a permis de financer le
projet hilaïque ou highlight il dit je
me suis rendu compte que je m'étais
engagé dans un projet qui était morné et
il parle d'un budget pour cette
association de trois francs cissous on
parle quand même de 355000 euros cette
déclaration elle vous a pas fait réagir
alors réagir sur le fait que
c'est une opération qui démarre avec du
retard ce qui est assez classique qui
démarre donc en septembre et en octobre
elle est mornée
ça c'était ça c'est interroge parce que
si on considère quand on est responsable
d'une association que le projet est
morné et bien à ce moment-là on doit
dire bon ben écoutez on arrête les frais
on voit avec l'administration comment
faire pour arrêter ce contrat mais on va
pas plus loin en réalité c'est poursuivi
malgré tout alors que il n'y avait
finalement plus de plus d'envie de
poursuivre ce projet c'est apparu très
nettement on arrive à la fin de cette
interview on se dit c'est un terrible
gâchis parle de on parle de d'un
assassinat terrible qui a bouleversé
toute la France et on termine avec voilà
cette polémique où on voit que il y a
beaucoup de manquements à tous les
niveaux vous êtes d'accord vous partagez
cette analyse que c'est un gâchis ah oui
ça je l'ai dit d'ailleurs à la ministre
c'est vrai que c'est un gâchis c'est
engag plusieurs titres d'abord parce que
quand on se réfère à un événement
dramatique comme celui-là et bien le
minimum qu'on attend d'un état c'est que
l'action soit poursuivie dans le temps
soit travaillé dans le temps et en tout
cas qui est pas l'idée comme on donne on
s'est passé c'est derrière etc ça ce
n'est pas acceptable et d'autre part ça
donne une image finalement de la
République elle-même celle que l'on veut
sauver celle que l'on veut défendre et
bien on donne une image détestable de
cette république et bien merci merci
Claude Raynal et donc c'était à priori
terminé le cycle d'audition est terminé
a priori vous nous le dites et donc vous
rendrez votre rapport il y a une date de
remise du rapport il y a pas il y a pas
la date mais la certitude que ça sera
avant le 13 juillet
[Musique]